what if all of us came in to create
something incredible when you pin your
passport
it doesn't say narrow be assumed or L
direct it says Kenya sounds have always
fascinated me every sound is unique and
beautiful if you just stop for a moment
and listen there's this whole other side
to things another one right there under
the surface
I am khaki Gandhi a Kenyan music
producer for a very long time I've had
this idea to gather sounds from all over
my homeland the sounds of instruments of
artists of the people and bring them
together in a way that no one has ever
done before with a bit of inspiration
from an old classic and with the help of
an amazing local artist we found a
direction but it needed something more
it needed so and there was only one way
to capture that so I left my studio
behind and went on an epic journey
I wanted to see if I could catch any
song what it is that makes us us
[Music]
[Music]
but when I sing or dance and I feel
their rhythm it's like I'm in a
different world I couldn't believe that
act can take you somewhere so with the
music you can fly
our grandfathers used music send
messages to people this is one of the
best thing that we need culture and
music can bring all tribes across the
country together with the journey done I
headed for home and back to the studio
to example the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I began this journey I thought I'd
find different sounds different cultures
but what I ended up finding made me feel
warm inside I found love I found love I
found
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]